moving again making more right here in
america and ensuring all workers benefit
he'll highlight the 367 000
manufacturing jobs that our economy has
created since he took office and he'll
underscore the vital role that the
federal government can play in bringing
workers and businesses together
and the president is going to call a
call in pittsburgh for for call oh sorry
he's going to
visit pittsburgh while he's visiting
pittsburgh he's going to talk about our
continued plans to out innovate out
build and out compete the world with the
sort of competitiveness legislation uh
that he has long championed of course we
love charts as you know here so this is
just a chart to show you all uh the
direction of economic growth which of
course it is moving in the right
direction also wanted to note that since
november 1st 14.5 million americans have
signed up for quality affordable health
care including more than 10 million who
enrolled through healthcare.gov the
highest numbers ever produced in an open
enrollment period this is in large part
thanks to the american rescue plan which
did more to lower costs and expand
access to health care than any action
since the passage of the affordable
care act
and everyone has until january 31st to
sign up for additional coverage with
that sterling wanted to kick us off
thank you jen a couple of questions on
the supreme court now that justice
breyer's uh retirement is official sure
and a quick foreign policy one
the president just said that he intends
to nominate someone by the end of
february
we have seen some slippage in past white
house deadlines that have been nominees
was an example recently so how hard and
fast is the end of february deadline the
president just set for for enhancing or
do you see a scenario worth living too
much well the president said he intends
to nominate so that is uh it makes clear
that this is a priority for him he will
obviously be spending time on it as i
think you heard him say as well he's
already been reviewing uh bios of
potential candidates that's something
that he's been doing since last year
and
but beyond that darlene i think the
president also knows from his long
history as former chairman of the senate
judiciary committee uh and as someone as
the vice president when when there were
two supreme court nominees confirmed
that you want to pick uh the right
person and he takes his role seriously
including the importance of
the consultation with the senate is
there anything you can add on how
quickly he would like to see the nominee
clear the confirmation process once he
names that individual
i'm not here to set deadlines uh it is
clear that the president's focus is
going to be as you heard him say on the
process of selecting a nominee someone
who will be qualified uh who as you
think you heard him say who will be
worthy of the decency and excellency of
justice breyer's legacy somebody with
character experience and integrity
and that will be a rigorous process but
that is the next step in the process and
of course beyond that he will be working
closely with chair durbin ranking member
grassley and other members of the senate
judiciary committee to confirm the
nominee as expeditiously as possible one
more on that before the quick foreign
policy question he said at the news
conference last week that he kind of
underestimated the level of gop
pushed back to him and his agenda and
i'm
we all think that his nominee will not
be spared any pushback so
how interested is the president in a
bipartisan confirmation vote for the
nominee or would he be um you know open
to a democrats democrats only
confirmation vote well darlene as you
heard the president say directly he's
going to work in good faith with
senators of both parties and there are
historic parts of these processes that
include uh cons
the advice
receiving the advice welcome the advice
welcoming the advice from members of
both parties and that's something he
certainly intends to do as you heard him
say i expect we'll have more details on
what that will look like uh in the
coming days and he's also grateful uh
two republicans to the republican
members who have already indicated they
plan to work with him but i think we
also shouldn't
should be clear about some of the games
that we're already seeing indications of
out there we have not mentioned a single
name we have not put out a list uh the
president made very clear he has not
made a selection
and there are if anyone is saying they
plan to characterize whoever he
nominates after throw consideration with
both parties as radical before they know
literally anything about who she is
they just obliterated their own
credibility so our intention is to not
play games the president's intention is
to consult with members of both parties
and his intention is to nominate a
qualified uh candidate uh who uh after
after uh completing a rigorous process
who's worthy of the excellence and
decency of briar's legacy and then the
foreign policy question is uh has the
president already spoken with uh
president zolinski of ukraine it's uh
happening this afternoon shortly and i
expect we'll have a readout of that as
soon as it happens
sure go ahead uh who here at the white
house is helping the president to sort
of lead this search effort is is this
ron claim who's helping him go through
this process and would he then be the
person to kind of uh shepherd the
nominees through the hill process as
well through meetings and such sure well
first the vice president will play a
central role uh in this process and the
president intends to consult with her
very closely obviously she has a long
history as a former attorney general as
a member of the judiciary community
committee and he respects her opinion
greatly in addition to the vice
president ron klain will of course play
a role dana remus cedric richmond uh
paige herwig who's a member of our
council's office and louisa terrell as
has been standard uh in the past
we would anticipate bringing in
additional expertise from the outside to
advise during the confirmation process
would expect we would have that team in
place prior to a selection uh but that
is not finalized at this point
and now that we
you know have heard the president speak
publicly about this i wonder if you can
take us sort of back maybe a little bit
in time when did the president first
learn of justice breyer's uh intent to
retire and you know how is he informed
you could just explain a little bit of
the backstory sure well first as you
heard the president say and you've heard
us say this was justice breyer's
decision to make on his own timeline
and through his own conditions he
determined so we aren't going to lay out
more specifics from here in terms of uh
when the president was aware uh the
president uh i can tell you that justice
breyer uh hand delivered uh the letter
uh to the president this morning that
you saw released by the supreme court
and that was the formal notification
from justice breyer and i asked you
about this yesterday just wondering if
you had a chance to look into it just
confirming is it the white house's view
that the vice president does have the
authority to break
a tie in a senate confirmation i know
you asked me that i know there was
historic precedent on that front um but
i will double check and see uh and i'm
i'm sorry i apologize for not getting
back to you on that go ahead just wanted
to clarify one thing you said to darlene
that he's been reviewing bios of justice
potential nominee since last year
i think for those of us who covered the
campaign it may have been since the
transition now that he's been reviewing
sometimes the campaign actually yeah
since the spring of since the spring of
2020 when he said that he was going to
get a shortlist i'm aware of when he
made that comment of course but in terms
of when he's been reviewing bios as
president since last year now he was
inaugurated last year so uh but he did
as uh as with jen just noted uh make a
commitment on the campaign which you
heard him say he absolutely intends to
deliver on which is to nominate the
first african-american woman to the
supreme court uh ron claine and dana
remus have been involved uh in
consulting with the president preparing
bios for him and that's something he has
looked at since last year we've never
had a president who spent eight years
reviewing judicial nominees as a vice
president
and 36 years reviewing
every judicial nominee before the senate
when he was on the judiciary committee
what does he bring to this process as
now president that other presidents
perhaps haven't
given that experience
well without comparing to past
presidents what i can tell you he brings
to the role is uh an appreciation for
the solemn importance of his
responsibility as president
and
a recognition of
the
historic role that this process plays
including the importance of selecting
somebody who's eminently qualified which
he has every intention of doing and
consulting uh with democrats and
republicans in the senate um you know he
is somebody who and i think you heard
him say this that is why i think he
wanted to convey very clearly that this
will be a rigorous process that he
wants to seek a candidate who's worthy
of the excellence and decency of justice
breyer's legacy that he will meet with
potential nominees he will study their
records carefully and he is going to
take all of the advice he can get so
what he brings to it is experience and
also
a recognition of the solemn importance
of the role any president plays in in
selecting a nominee to serve in a
lifetime appointment on the supreme
court
go ahead jen can you detail some of the
groups that the white house or perhaps
the president will be speaking to
outside of the white house or that they
have already spoken to this point as he
goes through the process of coming up
with the best possible candidate for the
court sure we will be consulting with a
range of groups obviously we just
announced the justices uh retirement uh
today uh i can get you more details on
that i expect in the coming days as that
process
commences
some of those conversations have already
taken place i imagine in some form right
so there are certainly because it looks
like getting to this place you knew the
inuit opening could exist at some point
certainly and as you know peter there
are a range of uh groups that have been
preparing for the potential for a
vacancy on the supreme court i will just
reiterate that the president's view has
always been that is up to the decision
of every individual supreme court
justice to determine uh when they will
resign or when they will retire and that
has how he has asked all of us to
conduct ourselves but there have been a
range of groups out there who have been
compiling their own lists
especially given the president's
commitment to nominating an
african-american woman the first to ever
serve on the supreme court and certainly
we have been consulting and we'll
continue to consult with them about
their views follow up on the foreign
policy question i know you'll give us a
readout at some point but obviously the
president goes into these calls with an
expectation of what message he wants to
deliver so what is the president's
message to the ukrainian president today
as we've witnessed this continued uh
build-up of troops along the ukrainian
border of russia well i would view this
call uh as part of regular engagement
with the ukrainian government with the
ukrainian government this will be the
third time the president and uh and
president zelinski have spoken in just
the last few weeks since december uh
they'll discuss the latest diplomatic
and deterrence efforts with russia the
president will reaffirm the united
states commitment to supporting
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity and our commitment to nothing
about ukraine without ukraine but this
is more of a check-in call than it is a
call where there is a specific
announcement being delivered
has changed its assessment has the biden
administration changed its assessment
that a russian invasion is imminent
well i would say that we have said since
last week uh that we have seen
preparations and build up at the border
uh and that an invasion could come at
any time our assessment has not changed
since that point and then can you just
talk about last thought on this topic
which is one of the complicating factors
here is that russia is now surrounding
ukraine from a variety of different
places right they're not just on the
east they're on the north they're on the
south as well they're in in belarus so
can you describe how that complicates
the decision-making process now or what
challenges that poses for you and just
the fact that they are now in a third
country in belarus what message that
sends to the united states
well i would say there's a couple of
a couple of ways we look at that peter
one is
as you know we're continuing to strongly
encourage u.s citizens who are in
ukraine to depart ukraine because we
watch closely and while we don't and
we're not predicting what president
putin may do we certainly are watching
closely the uh build-up of tens of
thousands of troops on the border and
also um the fact that we want to ensure
there are ample ways for american
citizens to depart ukraine uh should
they should they decide to leave ukraine
we're certainly encouraging them to do
that uh the second uh the second impact
i would say is that uh we're in close
consultation with our european partners
uh about their own security concerns uh
and uh certainly in close consultation
with them and our nato allies who are in
the region and in surrounding countries
about what security needs they have and
that is something they are watching
closely as you know we announced just a
couple of days ago that we have 8 500
troops at the ready as part of a nato
force that would be a decision made
through consultation in the nato
alliance uh not by the united states but
uh certainly they're all watching uh the
uh build up uh and the movements of
troops by the russians the number
remains
though for us for today correct um i
would point you to the apartment of
defense if there's any updates but not
that i am tracking any changes in that
front
you expect to have a short list for the
president of the supreme court nominees
i expect we will have a short list um
sorry i can give you an exact prediction
of that i will note steve that the
president has been reviewing uh bios so
i'm not going to define what that being
the short list but i will tell you that
he has already started reviewing
potential candidates time frame for
getting someone confirmed would you like
to have it done by jews or what what are
you thinking as expeditiously as
possible steve but the president also
notes and i think this is important
because i know there have been a range
of calls out there for a timeline his
view and this goes back to ed's earlier
question this is a
a nominating someone to serve in a
lifetime appointment on the supreme
court we want that to happen as
expeditiously as possible and we don't
uh we will call out games as we see them
but the president's focus is on
nominating the right person he said he
is intense to do that in february and
then working closely with the chairman
and ranking member from there do you
expect him to only consider sitting
judges
well the president believes that sitting
judges can make excellent justices uh
but he does not believe that is a
prerequisite last thing on on ukraine
russia says it needs time to review
their u.s response to their demands yeah
and will not rush to conclusions is this
a
falling
at all is this a positive thing what do
you what's your interpretation
well uh
i think as you've heard our secretary of
state and our national security adviser
and others convey uh we don't know if
the russians are playing games on
diplomacy we hope not um and our
intention we are certainly pursuing uh
diplomacy uh with a level of seriousness
uh and an intention in uh leaving that
door open and pursuing that path should
should uh should they be open to it um
but they have conveyed their reviewing
uh what was sent to them um and uh
that's a part of the diplomatic process
and as you heard our secretary of state
say yesterday he anticipates he'll speak
with his counterpart foreign minister
lavrov soon
go ahead um i noticed today david
axelrod tweeted out a series of um
uh votes for previous supreme court uh
nominees that were nearly unanimous in
the senate um and the president's glory
days
right the president seemed to sort of
lament uh the current sort of
environment that he's operating in in
that in his remarks just now um have you
talked to him about that and is is there
to sort of gets to an earlier question
as well a little bit but is there a
um a desire on his part uh to try to
find a way to um pick someone
who
could have a broad the broadest possible
appeal and and what's his
uh sort of attitude about you know after
all these years he's pursued the
presidency he's been vice president now
this is his one opportunity to do this
and he's in this moment in washington
where um you know it's very unlike
the environment that he spent most of
his career in
that's true and he is not naive to that
and you heard him speak about this
broadly at the press conference last
week as well but i would also note that
last year president biden won
confirmation of the most judges in his
first year in office of any president
since president reagan he's won
confirmation of the most lower court
judges in the first year of a presidency
since president kennedy he has nominated
and confirmed more african-american
women to the circuit court ever in
history the number eight that he has
nominated and confirmed as more total
than ever in history so i would note
that even in the environment we are
living in a divisive environment at
times where if you take voting rights
for example where i know i've said this
a lot but it's a good example 16
senators who have supported voting
rights in the past don't support it now
we have still been able to make historic
progress on moving forward judicial
nominees
his intention and his focus is not on
is not on navigating out the legislative
game playing it is on
selecting and nominating an eminently
qualified african-american woman to
serve on the court
and he will work closely in good faith
with democrats and republicans
on the process to consult them in
advance and then to move through the
confirmation process but that is how
he's going to approach it and the
question of whether or not
that person could earn
support from republicans isn't likely to
be an influencing factor as he picks
among the possible qualified candidates
well i don't think we should buy into
that game playing and i don't think the
president believes that you know if you
look at what the president um has
committed to uh nominating the first
african-american woman it's been over
230 years as we know since the supreme
court came into being a black woman has
never served on it and the president's
view is that anyone who's saying that
that's not possible or we can't find
the most eminently qualified person uh
that's ludicrous i mean that's
suggesting that uh black women should
not be a part of the most important
corner nation that there aren't black
women who have distinguished themselves
by rising to the top of the legal
profession with the strongest
credentials imaginable there are many of
you are reporting different lists of
names of many potentially qualified
candidates uh so his focus is going to
be on pursuing this pro this process uh
with rigor uh with the uh seriousness
that it warrants and he is hopeful he
will have a partnership in approaching
it from members of the senate
go ahead
um just put a little bit of finer point
on what you just got to at the end of it
yeah there have already been
conservative commentators um
talking a bit about
why a black woman that's to commit to
that is reverse racism or
some kind of signaling
um a virtual virtual signaling or
something like that what do you say to
people who are saying that that is
you know an inappropriate uh way to
to set up prerequisites for who people
well first we'd say that the fact that
no black woman has been nominated shows
a deficiency of the past election
processes not a lack of qualified
candidates to be nominated to the
supreme court i'd also note i've heard
that some conservatives may be fans of
president reagan
and when he former president reagan
and when he nominated sandra day
o'connor he said quote judge o'connor's
confirmation symbolizes the richness of
opportunity that still abides in america
opportunity that permits persons of any
sex age or any race from every section
and every walk of life to aspire and
achieve in a manner never before even
dreamed about in human history i'd also
note if you look at the president's own
record not only has he nominated the
most af the highest number of black
women to serve on the circuit court in
the appellate court but he is also
nominated across the board the highest
level of ivy league nominees right he is
he has qualified he has nominated a
broad sway of extremely qualified
experienced and credentialed nominees
credentialed nominees and done that by
also making them incredibly diverse
and so the president's view is that it
is long past time to have a black woman
on the supreme court uh and that it
again reflects uh uh
challenges or deficiencies in the past
processes
you know there are also the questions
that you kind of got at it with the ivy
league degrees point um are you is the
president thinking about diversity of
backgrounds so
people who maybe have worked in
uh
civil rights work or
um who didn't go to harvard or you know
law school
or or another another criterion is he
thinking about their age and to what
extent can you say sort of what paul
park he's looking at there
i can't give you any specifics on the
age but i will tell you this um as a
proud state school graduate myself
and the president as you know is not a
graduate of an ivy league school he is
also nominated judges from a range of
backgrounds i was
trying to give you a sense of how
qualified and the extensive credentials
of the judges he has nominated to date
but as i noted earlier i can't remember
who asked the question uh but he uh well
being a judge in the past certainly
could make a great justice that's not a
prerequisite for him either so he will
look at a broad array of candidates if
they just ask a foreign policy question
um as you prepare for the german
chancellor to visit the week after next
does the administration believe germany
should stop blocking estonia from
shipping weapons to ukraine
and doesn't germany's position undercut
the unity
between
u.s and europeans that that the
administration has been talking about so
much when it comes to russia well our
view is that unity does not mean uh
identical uh and that there are a range
of capacities capabilities legal
authorities
that different countries have
and what is most important is being
united
against uh the bellicose rhetoric uh the
buildup of troops and the potential of
russia invading a sovereign country the
sovereign country of ukraine and we have
found germany to be
very much united with us in that effort
as we have found with other uh other
european countries specifically on the
estonian weapons
again there are a range of capacities
and capabilities different countries are
going to be providing germany has
provided a range other countries have
provided a range uh what's most
important is looking at the totality of
how we're all working to help support
ukraine
good two quick questions on the courts
uh first of all the president's talking
about a rigorous deliberative process
are you confident that that can happen
in the time frame that that senator
schumer is talking about of about a one
month confirmation process from start to
finish once the announcement is made
that's not a timeline we have set uh
what our focus is on and the president's
focus is on first of course is selecting
through a rigorous process uh a
candidate who's eminently qualified who
again meets is worthy of the excellency
and dignity and decency of justice
breyer's
legacy and then the president's
intention even in advance of that of
course is to work in good faith with
leaders and ranking members and chairs
of both parties to move this process
forward he wants that process to move
forward expeditiously uh and he is
certainly hopeful that uh everyone will
come to the table
in good faith oh okay
but that was i care about child care um
but um but but we are not uh here to set
a timeline uh from here uh our uh focus
is on uh of course the present
nominating highly qualified nominee
consulting with the senate and getting
her confirmed given that that's the
timeline that the senate democrats are
already talking about is a one-month
process something the white house is
comfortable with do you think that could
work or do you think that might rush the
process
again i think i spoke to what our view
is
good
thanks jen um can you explain a little
bit more first off why the end of
february uh deadline that the president
said why did he commit himself to that
what is it about that timeline that uh
appeals to him
i think he was attempting to give all of
you a sense of his process and how much
of a priority uh this is uh for him to
put forward
an eminently qualified nominee looking
backward before today
when was the last time that the
president spoke with justice brian i'm
not going to get into details of his
conversations or engagements with
justice breyer again it was justice
spryer's decision to retire and if he
wants to speak to any conversations or
his process or notification process
he can certainly do that can you say i
mean have they spoken within the last
couple of months have they spoken
several times over the last time i
appreciate your effort but we uh we are
going to leave that to justice pryor to
outline should he decide to and question
on a different note um the bind
administration has approved more
uh oil and gas drilling and it's first
year than the trunk administration did
in its first year it set a record for
the largest offshore lease sale last
year in the gulf of mexico is now
preparing several other major lease
sales can you explain
why this administration hasn't done more
curb fossil fuel production on public
lands and waters your allies in the
environmental community who say look
there are other levers you could pull to
accomplish more of this well i would
first say we have an entirely different
policy from the trump administration
on addressing the crisis the climate
crisis which i'm not even sure that they
acknowledged certainly not in the same
way that president biden and our entire
team has and we've taken a range of
steps including in advocating for a
historic investment in addressing the
climate crisis
that we are still working to move
forward in congress but we've taken a
range of additional steps beyond that as
you know sean i think and just to be on
the level with everybody a big part of
that is because of court cases uh and
legal challenges that have uh made it
uh
it made it impossible for us to stop uh
many of these leases and uh that is uh
the reasoning for it
but some
i understand what you're saying on the
on the legal challenge but i mean some
climate activists say that there are
other ways either through oh you know
reopening the environmental review
process for those lease sales delaying
them canceling them out right like there
are other levers that can be pulled even
in the face of those court challenges uh
to well i would say a court challenge is
a significant barrier to implementing
our intended policy
and that is of course not consistent
with our policy
keeping many of these open but
we have an obligation to of course abide
by the law i would note that there are
also a range of steps that we have taken
to address the climate crisis that go
far beyond legislation and certainly
beyond the challenges we have because of
those curb posed by the court challenges
um including tackling uh super
pollutants phasing down uh
hydrofluorocarbons uh rallying the world
on to focus on methane in glasgow
this summer we stood with auto workers
and america's big car manufacturers
derailed plans to boost electric
vehicles we put america on track for one
of every two cars sold to be zero
emissions within the decade you heard a
lot of ceos yesterday speak to how
important addressing the climate crisis
is even to their industries that's
something the president is committed to
so i don't think our
approach could be any starkly more
starkly different uh from the approach
of the former president
go ahead
the last count that i saw
had the president giving 42 of 81
nominations confirmed
judicial nominations confirmed through
the senate
a lot of them you know a good number of
them had a close margin in terms of the
senate vote yeah is the president
expecting that same kind of unity within
the democratic caucus with whomever
nominee should be just given how
difficult it's been getting unity on
other portions of the agenda
well again the president as you heard
him say hasn't made a decision um he the
only decision he's made is to nominate a
black woman to the supreme court the
first in history one who's eminently
qualified
and that is his intention and he intends
to do that once he concludes a rigorous
process
i would note that he has found
eminently qualified nominees for judges
that have been confirmed 42 i believe is
the correct number historic number of of
diverse nominees to serve and judge
ships around the country and certainly
he's hopeful that when he puts that
nominee forward there'll be strong
support uh from a range of senators a
quick note on student loans i know you
had a good deal on it yesterday is the
president
worried at all about
slapping you know millions of student
borrowers with their monthly obligations
you know of hundreds or thousands of
dollars toward their student loan
payments you know several months ahead
of an election cycle when he's then
probably going to turn around to those
same college educated voters and ask
them to come out and vote for democrats
in november
well i think first no one has paid uh
been required to pay a single dime a
federal student loan since the president
took office i'm not sure there's another
time
in history where that has been the case
in the first year of a presidency
at the same time our economy is seeing
one of the strongest recoveries in
history
and the president has also taken
historic steps to
provide relief
and cancel he's canceled 15 billion
dollars of student loans during his
first year in office obviously as we get
closer to the timeline in may we will
have to make a decision about what's
next um and we've obviously been clear
on what we're preparing for but
the president's going to make these
decisions based on what we're seeing in
economic data and what we feel uh is
certainly needed at the time in the
country would you say to borrowers who
look at you know the 11 i think the 15
billion number was one you shared
yesterday i'm dead that he's cancelled
so far
and they say
being canceled that why can't he cancel
my debt as well if they're not in the
particular groups and classes of
borrowers
i would say if that congress sends us
him a bill to cancel ten thousand
dollars in student debt he'd be happy to
sign that into law
go ahead
two today uh lawrence tribe told real
clear politics yesterday that he'd
likely stand by his past comments the
vice president can't break a tie to
confirm scottish nominee i know you said
you were going to check on the specifics
yesterday so i was just wondering if
there's an update on where the
administration stands on this oh mary
just asked that question oh it's okay
i'm happy to get back to you if we have
an illegal analysis from here and then
um on covid we've seen an effort from a
few other countries to include a push
for living a healthier lifestyle as part
of its pandemic response there's been
studies indicating efforts like weight
loss can help prevent some of the more
serious effects of coca-19 why isn't the
president included a push for healthier
lifestyles in his coma messaging in
addition to pushing americans to get
vaccinated
first we rely on the advice and guidance
of our public health officials on how to
best protect yourself from
hospitalization and and death from kovid
and we know that the most effective
steps anyone can take are to get
vaccinated get boosted wear a mask
and those are the steps that we're
certainly focusing on if they decide
those are steps that are warranted and
have a huge impact on outcomes and they
want to share those we'd certainly echo
those but we really refer to our public
health officials and experts it hasn't
been a advice from the public health
officials that the president's been
speaking to again we do it we do
briefings with our public health
officials every week multiple times a
week and i think what's most important
to note is what we know is most
effective which is getting vaccinated
getting boosted wearing a mask
and those are the uh those are the
components and the steps that we're
really focusing our attention on
encouraging
go ahead thank you jen so much i have a
quick follow-up on peter's question and
tomorrow i mean
uh if the united states and ukraine are
so close together working together in
close coordination why does the white
house say invasion is even ukraine save
is not
well i think i just said that our
assessment is the same as it was last
week which is that we're watching
obviously tens of thousands of troops
build troops uh build up
at the border we can't get in the mind
of president putin
but obviously an invasion could happen
at any time but we have not made a
prediction of that the president hasn't
made a prediction of the timing um and
again
we'll let others a set assess what tens
of thousands of troops at the border
means
yesterday ukrainian russia sat down for
the first time in a long time along with
france and germany without the united
states and they agreed to
keep the caesar cease fire in eastern
ukraine and talk again in two weeks
does the white house believe they can
bring peace without the united states
being involved in the talks
yeah we fully support international
efforts including the normandy format
which is what you're referring to to
de-escalate the situation and negotiate
a diplomatic resolution to the
russian-led conflict in eastern ukraine
we stand ready to support any sincere
efforts at progress from all sides and
of course this is a positive step
one more uh besides the the crisis in
ukraine this week alone
isis launched the biggest attack in
syria
in in years uh we had a police officer
in iraq
in a veto again the u.n chief said
afghanistan is hanging by trade people
are starving and freezing
after the united states left the country
so is this what american leadership or
american bank look like and
uh can you say this is a winning foreign
policy
that was a lot wracked up in that
question uh what is your question
exactly i'm asking we'll see we see
things happening with isis that we
haven't seen in years
launching big attack in syria and iraq
we see people uh in afghanistan hungary
is starving freezing in the united
states um i'm asking
yesterday you were asking the question
what happened the last year after one
year president office in office uh in
foreign policy and you say america is
back so i want my question is
just yesterday we saw so much happen in
the world is this what american back
means
well isis has been a terrorist
organization for many years through the
course before president biden took
office they've been terrorizing people
uh for many years
that is not new as of the last year
and we have spoken out about that
at every time when it has been
appropriate to do exactly that i would
say the president's role over the last
year as i've talked about a bit in here
has been rebuilding our relationships
around the world that have been frayed
we're afraid during the prior four years
reminding other countries around the
world that we are a reliable partner a
reliable ally and the fact that we have
had more than 100 engagements with
countries around the world at a range of
levels and formats
as we look to the aggressive behavior of
russia speaks to that speaks to it
doesn't happen by accident that's why we
have a united front
as we're looking at the potential
actions of president putin uh so i think
that speaks to the work the president
has done over the past year go ahead a
question about brazil very quickly my
country
so the white house says brazil is a
strategic partner in the hemisphere uh
but so far one year after in office
president biden hasn't spoken yet with
the brazilian president
i wonder why that conversation is still
i know that is a lot of other priorities
but why uh just completely ignoring this
conversation with brazil i know that
brazil is pushing to have this
conversation well our secretary of state
our chief diplomat spoke just a few
weeks ago with his counterpart about our
shared priorities including a need for a
strong united response against further
russian aggression against ukraine uh
we're obviously consulting broadly
across the board um and so i think
that certainly is an appropriate very
high level engagement and when there's a
call with the president we'll let you
know go ahead i think we're moving on go
ahead thank you jeff um my question is
more on the human element of what's
happening in ukraine uh in 2014 after
russia invaded crimea more than a
million ukrainians sought asylum in
neighboring countries um ukrainian
diplomats in europe are now saying that
if russia invades now that there will be
many many millions more um what
preparations are being made to work with
the eu to alleviate this potential
refugee crisis is the u.s considering
allowing ukrainians to enter the country
without a visa or is it even just
material support for potentially housing
and feeding millions of ukrainians who
are going to be displaced well i was
saying you touched on this a little bit
in your question but since the conflict
began almost eight years ago we have
provided uh there has been a
huge humanitarian challenges in ukraine
most of the needs are in the easternmost
regions of course bordering russia
including donetsk and luhansk where
fighting along active frontlines have
resulted in civilian deaths and injuries
and damage to civilian infrastructure
including critical water supplies that's
already been happening over the past
several years um and obviously covet 19
has exacerbated that
usaid has a disaster expert in the
country who's monitoring the situation
closely coordinating with other donors
assessing the evolving humanitarian
needs of the ukrainian people and
liaising with partners to determine what
steps may be needed now obviously if
russia invades uh you know that could
create and exacerbate existing
humanitarian needs stemming from these
years of conflict and we have over the
course of the last year
eight years sorry provided more than 350
million 51 million dollars to vulnerable
communities across ukraine including
nearly 141 million dollars from usaid
food safe working drinking water shelter
emergency health care winterization
services and what usa
usaid and our team on the ground will
continue to do is assess what the needs
are and make decisions accordingly so i
can't predict for you what that will
look like obviously our preference would
be for a diplomatic path to avoid an
invasion but we have a long history of
delivering urgent humanitarian
assistance in ukraine and we're prepared
to do that as needs a warrant
more broadly um what lessons did the
president learn after the fall of kabul
which led to its own refugee crisis what
what
you know did he i guess learn from what
at the time was viewed as kind of a
fumbled response initially to hundreds
of thousands of afghans seeking to flee
the country
as it relates to ukraine or just in
general i mean as as it could
potentially be applied to ukraine
well i would say ending a 20-year war
that was failed where we were spending
billions and trillions of dollars
every month and every year is a very
different circumstance than what we're
looking at here which is the build-up of
russian troops on a border in ukraine
this doesn't involve us troops in
ukraine right so very different
circumstance um i would say um how what
we're applying i would say let me let me
take it in a slightly different
direction what the president has learned
from his time uh in the foreign policy
world and working on global diplomatic
issues over the past several decades is
that it's imperative to work closely
with your partners and allies and
approach it from a united front
that we need to contingency plan and
have a range of options even as we're
leaving the door open to diplomacy which
is certainly always the preferred path
and i think that's what you're seeing
him do uh now and that as it relates to
russia which is a very different entity
of course than what we were dealing with
in afghanistan that the um you know
unending ability and capacity for the
country to
and the leadership i should say to
spread misinformation um to uh to uh you
know lay the attempt to lay the
predicate uh for an invasion is
something that we have to be quite
mindful of that's a very different
circumstance but certainly he uh leans
on and uh and uh of his decades of
experience in foreign policy go ahead
hi um yesterday uh senator schatz who
chairs the senate indian affairs
committee wrote to the president asking
him to commute the sentence of leonard
peltier
and native american activist to
convicted of murder in a very
controversial trial about four decades
ago is that something the president is
considering or taking a look at
i don't have anything to predict for you
on that front
i think we have to wrap up everyone
thanks so much have a great day we'll
see you tomorrow thanks so much
okay everyone have a good day